depuis que la Révolution Libyenne a éclaté,
inspirée par les vagues de mobilisation massive
des révolutions tunisienne et égyptienne.
Je me suis allié avec de nombreux Libyens à l'intérieur et hors de Libye
pour appeler à un jour de révolte
et lancer la révolution contre le régime tyrannique de Kadhafi.
Et voilà, ce fut une grande révolution.
De jeunes Libyennes et Libyens étaient en première ligne
demandant la chute du régime,
clamant des slogans de liberté, de dignité et de justice sociale.
Ils ont montré un courage exemplaire
en affrontant la cruelle dictature de Kadhafi.
Ils ont montré un grand sens de solidarité
du fin fond de l'Est jusqu'à l'Ouest lointain, en allant jusqu'au Sud.
Finalement, après une période de six mois d'une terrible guerre
et près de 50 000 morts,
nous avons réussi à libérer notre pays et renverser le tyran.
(Applaudissements)
Toutefois, Kadhafi a laissé derrière lui un lourd fardeau,
un héritage de tyrannie, de corruption et les germes de la discorde.
Durant quatre décennies, le régime tyrannique de Kadhafi
a détruit les infrastructures ainsi que la culture et le tissu moral de la société libyenne.
Bien consciente des ravages et des défis,
j'ai tenu, avec de nombreuses autres femmes, à reconstruire la société civile libyenne,
en appelant à une transition ouverte et juste
vers la démocratie et la réconciliation nationale.
Près de 200 organisations ont été créées à Benghazi
pendant et immédiatement après la chute de Kadhafi --
près de 300 à Tripoli.
Après 33 années d'exil, je suis rentrée en Libye,
et avec un grand enthousiasme,
j'ai commencé à organiser des ateliers
sur le renforcement des capacités, sur le développement humain des compétences requises pour diriger.
Avec un fantastique groupe de femmes,
j'ai cofondé la Plateforme pour la Paix des Femmes Libyennes,
un mouvement de femmes, de dirigeants, venant de différents horizons,
afin de faire pression en faveur de la prise de pouvoir sociopolitique des femmes
et en faveur de notre droit
à une participation égalitaire pour l’instauration de la démocratie et de la paix.
J'ai fait face à un environnement très difficile juste avant les élections,
un environnement qui se polarisait de plus en plus,
un environnement modelé par une politique égoïste de domination et d'exclusion.
J'ai dirigé une initiative de la Plateforme pour la Paix des Femmes Libyennes
destinée à faire pression pour obtenir une loi électorale plus ouverte,
une loi qui donnerait à tout citoyen, quelque soit son profil,
le droit de voter et de se présenter,
et plus important encore, qui établirait une parité des candidats hommes et femmes
dans les partis politiques,
verticalement et horizontalement dans leurs listes,
créant ainsi, ce que j'appelle, la "liste zip".
Au final, notre initiative a été adoptée et fut une réussite.
Les femmes ont obtenu 17,5% du Congrès National
lors des premières élections organisées en 52 ans.
(Applaudissements)
Néanmoins, peu à peu, l'euphorie des élections,
et de la révolution toute entière,
a commencé à s'atténuer --
car chaque jour était rythmé par l'annonce de violences.
Un jour, on s'est réveillé avec la nouvelle
du pillage d'anciennes mosquées et de tombes soufis.
Un autre jour, on a appris
l'assassinat de l'ambassadeur américain et l'attaque du consulat.
l'assassinat d'officiers de l'armée.
Et tous les jours, les journées commencent avec la loi des milices
et leur constante violation des droits humains des prisonniers
et leur piétinement de la loi.
Notre société, façonnée par un idéal révolutionnaire,
s'est davantage polarisée
et s'est éloignée des idéaux et des principes
de liberté, dignité et justice sociale
qui étaient les nôtres au commencement.
Intolérance, exclusion et vengeance
sont devenus les icônes [des conséquences] de la révolution.
Je suis ici aujourd'hui non pas pour vous inspirer
avec le succès de notre "liste zip" et des élections.
Aujourd'hui, je suis plutôt ici pour avouer
que, en tant que nation, nous avons fait le mauvais choix et pris les mauvaises décisions.
Nous n'avons pas bien défini nos priorités.
Car les élections n'ont pas amené la paix, la stabilité et la sécurité en Libye.
La "liste zip" et la parité entre les candidats hommes et femmes
ont-elles amené la paix et la réunion nationale ?
Non.
Mais alors, que s'est-il passé ?
Pourquoi notre société continue-t-elle d'être polarisée et dominée
par une politique égoïste de domination et d'exclusion, tant de la part des hommes que des femmes ?
Ce qui manquait n'était peut-être pas seulement les femmes,
mais les valeurs féminines de compassion, pardon et ouverture.
Notre société a besoin d'une discussion à l'échelle nationale et de l'instauration d'un consensus
plus qu'elle n'a besoin d'élections,
qui n'ont fait que renforcer la polarisation et la division.
Notre société a besoin d'une représentation qualitative de la femme
plus que d'une représentation numérique, quantitative.
Nous devons arrêter d'agir sous l'influence de la colère et d'appeler à la révolte.
Nous devons commencer à agir afin de créer la compassion et le pardon.
Il nous faut développer un discours féminin
qui non seulement honore mais aussi mette en pratique
le pardon plutôt que la vengeance, la collaboration plutôt que la compétition,
l'ouverture plutôt que l'exclusion.
Ce sont les idéaux dont a désespérément besoin
une Libye déchirée par la guerre, pour établir la paix.
Car la paix réclame une alchimie,
une alchimie qui vient de l'imbrication, de l'alternance entre
les points de vue féminin et masculin.
C'est ça le rassemblement, le vrai "zip".
Et nous devons l'accepter au fond de nous-mêmes
avant de le faire au niveau sociopolitique.
Comme le dit un verset coranique :
"Salam" -- paix -- " est la parole de Dieu, rempli de miséricorde, raheem."
De là, le mot "raheem", connu dans toutes les traditions abrahamiques,
a la même racine en arabe que le mot "rahem" -- utérus --
symbolisant la nature féminine qui englobe l'humanité toute entière
et de laquelle viennent l'homme et la femme,
toutes les tribus et tous les peuples.
Et ainsi, tout comme l'utérus enveloppe totalement l'embryon, qui grandit en lui,
la matrice divine de la compassion nourrit l'existence toute entière.
Ainsi, on nous dit "Mon pardon englobe toute chose."
Ainsi, on nous dit "Mon pardon prend le dessus sur ma colère."
Puissions-nous tous être dotés de la grâce du pardon.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.